All right. Good morning, everybody.
My name is Evanthea Rousos-Torres.
I am an assistant professor of medicine from the University of Southern California.
It's my pleasure to welcome you to AACR's Plenary Session Four, Advances
in Immunotherapy.
This morning, we're going to hear from four investigators representing their
respective research teams who will present data from early phase trials
investigating novel checkpoint and other immunotherapies in various different
solid tumor types, and four different discussants who will discuss their results.
Like to introduce yourself?
Sure. I'm Ryan Sullivan from Mass General Brigham Cancer Institute, and I'm
very excited for this plenary session.
And I'm going to stop talking so you can hear the real great science and
discussants for the rest of the time.
Great.
All right. So I'd like to first welcome our first speaker,
Dr. Alberto Giovanni Leone from the Fondazione
Istituto Nazionale dei Tumori di Milano, from Milan, Italy.
He'll be presenting the final results of the INFINITY study investigating
tremelimumab and durvalumab as definitive non-operative management for
MSI-high gastric cancers.
Good morning, everyone, and thank you for being here, and thanks to the
AACR for the big opportunity.
Today, I'm going to present the final results of cohort
two of INFINITY trial
evaluating a non-operative management strategy with tremelimumab
plus durvalumab in patients with resectable
MSI high gastric and gastroesophageal junction cancer.
I have no disclosures.
So let's start with the clinical context.
In resectable gastric and gastroesophageal junction adenocarcinoma,
MSI-high is associated with better survival,
but also with a lack of benefit from chemotherapy.
At the same time, we know that these tumors are highly sensitive
to immune checkpoint blockade. For example, in cohort
one of our INFINITY trial,
a short course of neoadjuvant dual
immunotherapy with the STRIDE regimen, tremelimumab plus durvalumab,
led to 60% of pathological complete
responses
and 80% of major pathological responses.
And so the key clinical question became, if
responses are this deep,
do all patients still need surgery?
And this was the rationale for cohort two.
We designed this trial to test whether a non-operative
management
could be a safe
and effective strategy for those patients achieving a clinical
complete response after only three months of dual immunotherapy.
This was the trial design. INFINITY was a Phase
2 singular multi-cohort trial.
Eligible patients had gastric or gastroesophageal
adenocarcinoma were MSI-high with
a deficient mismatch repair status, EBV negative,
and with a T2 or higher disease and any nodal
status.
Patients received STRIDE regimen consisting of tremelimumab,
the anti-CDL4 on day one as a single
flat dose of 300 milligrams, and durvalumab, the
anti-PD-L1,
1,500 milligrams as a flat dose every four weeks
for three cycles for a total duration of three months of therapy.
Between weeks 12 and 14, all patients underwent a
strict multimodal restaging.
Now, in cohort one, all patients underwent surgery
regardless of their clinical response.
In cohort two, only patients with an incomplete
response underwent salvage surgery, whereas patients who
achieved a clinical complete response, and later on we will see how we
defined the clinical complete response,
proceeded to the non-operative management pathway.
And this pathway consisted of an intensive
surveillance every 12 weeks up to two years with a CT
scan,
endoscopy with bite-on-bite biopsies, at least six
bite-on-bite biopsies, and tissue-informed ctDNA assessment
when technically feasible.
Importantly, after the results of cohort one
and following review by an independent data monitoring committee,
patients with a T4 disease were excluded from enrollment
in cohort two due to their low probability of achieving a
clinical complete response after only three months of
immunotherapy.
The primary endpoint was the two-year clinical complete response
rate without salvage surgery.
Now, this is critical. Clinical complete response was not
defined on one test only. It required all of the following to be
negative: a CT scan, a PET scan,
EGD with endoscopic ultrasound and bite-on-bite
biopsies, and tissue-informed ctDNA.
So it was a composite clinical, pathological, and molecular
definition.
Secondary endpoints included progression-free survival, overall survival,
gastrectomy-free survival, as well as safety, quality of life,
and exploratory translational analysis.
From January to December 2023,
we enrolled 18 patients, and 18 patients started treatment.
However, one patient withdrew consent after only one cycle of
immunotherapy and has been lost to follow-upSo
eventually, 17 patients were evaluable for the primary endpoint.
The table on the right shows the baseline features for the
intention-to-treat population.
And now let's move to the key results.
The clinical complete response rate at two years was
71%.
In details,
13 out of 17 patients achieved
clinical complete response
at the restaging between weeks 12 and 14 and
proceeded to the non-operative management pathway.
Among these, only one patient had a
locoregional recurrence four months after completion
of the immunotherapy,
has been surgically salvaged, and
has remained free of disease since then.
Four patients did not achieve clinical complete response,
so they underwent immediate salvage surgery.
And among these, one patient actually had a
pathological complete response on primary tumor, but not in the lymph
nodes.
Two patients had a moderate pathological response corresponding
to a Becker tumor regression grade of two,
and one patient had a poor pathological response corresponding to a Becker
grade of three.
Importantly,
three out of four of these patients had a positive tissue-informed
ctDNA at the restaging, whereas only one patient had a
ctDNA negative.
And here we can see the survival outcomes.
After a median follow-up of 27.1 months and
with a minimum follow-up of 24 months,
the results were very encouraging.
The 24-month progression-free survival was
94.1%.
The 24-month overall survival was 100%,
and the 24-month gastrectomy-free survival was
70.6%. So no patients died, no patients
required additional systemic treatment, nor radiotherapy.
The treatment was overall well-tolerated.
Seventy-two percent of patients had adverse events of any
grade, but only three patients, which is 17% of the
intention-to-treat population, had a grade 3 adverse event.
And in detail, we observed one case of hyperthyroidism,
two cases of increased gamma-glutamyl transferase, and one
case of colitis. All of these adverse events were
treated as per protocol and completely resolved.
No grade four or five adverse events occurred,
and just one month delay in durvalumab
administration due to immune-related grade two
nephritis was reported in one patient.
No cases of treatment discontinuation was reported.
And now let's see the quality of life results.
Quality of life was assessed using validated patient-reported
outcome instruments,
and these assessments were performed at the baseline, during treatment
at cycle two and three, and after treatment at the restaging time
point.
Overall quality of life was preserved throughout all the patient's
history without any clinically significant
deterioration across all the global or
functional or symptoms scales.
Let's move to the exploratory analysis.
In addition to the tissue-informed ctDNA analysis, which
was used to define clinical complete response, as I said
before,
we performed plasma-only ctDNA
analysis with a panel which hasn't been yet
validated for gastric cancer, so the results are totally exploratory.
At the baseline with this panel, ctDNA was detectable in
13 of the 17 patients, and among these,
84%
of patients had a complete clearance of ctDNA
after treatment. Whereas those patients who were negative
at the baseline remained undetectable even after treatment.
As we can see from the figure in the middle, higher baseline ctDNA
levels were associated with a lower probability
of achieving clinical complete response between weeks 12 and 14,
but with a p-value of 0.06, so not statistically significant
due to low numbers of our trial.
And the figure on the right shows that ctDNA
status at the restaging time point predicted
failure of achieving clinical complete response with a
sensitivity of 50% and a specificity of
100%. So not perfect sensitivity, but when
positive, high, very highly informative.
And finally, let's move to the transcriptomics.
Even within MSI-high tumors, we observed
substantial biological heterogeneity.
Among tumor samples collected at the baseline,
we identified
299 differentially expressed genes between
tumor samples from patients who achieved clinical complete
response versus those who did not.
And in detail, tumor samples from responders showed
upregulations of those genes involved in cytotoxic
activity and immune recognition.
Whereas tumor samples from non-respondersShowed
upregulation of those genes involved in stromal
activation and epithelial-mesenchymal transition
related programs.
The figure on the right shows the results from our deconvolution
analysis of bulk RNA sequencing data.
And we can see that higher baseline myeloid
infiltration was evident in tumor samples from
non-responders with a concordant trend toward an
enrichment of M2-like macrophages, as we had
already observed from tumor samples of non-responders from cohort
one, as per our previous publication on "Annals of Oncology."
So basically, these results shows there are two
different biological states, responders with a more
immune permissive microenvironment and
more active cytotoxic engagement, and non-responders
with stromal constraint and with features which are consistent
with immune exclusion.
To conclude,
a non-operative management strategy following three months
of tremelimumab plus durvalumab in
resectable MSI high gastric or
gastroesophageal junction cancer patients in carefully
selected patients is a viable option, is safe,
and has been already endorsed by NCCN in their guidelines.
However, the optimal strategy for these patients
in terms of treatment duration, treatment regimen, and
treatment goal still needs to be established in
larger randomized or adaptive trials.
And finally,
this approach in clinical practice would require shared
decision-making with patient
with a careful balance between the intensive surveillance which is needed in a
non-operative management pathway and a timely selective
surgery when and if needed.
I want to thank all the patients and their families for their trust,
for participating in our trial. I want to thank Gono Foundation, our
sponsor, and all the investigators across the Italian
participating centers.
A huge thanks goes to the GI oncology team at
Istituto Nazionale Tumori in Milan,
and especially I want to thank Dr. Raimondi who co-lead the project with me, Dr.
Manca for his invaluable support in results analysis,
and obviously my mentor, Dr. Filippo Pietrantonio,
who's been the driving force behind all of this and who
instilled in me the value and pride of conducting academic
research. So thank you all for your attention.
Thank you so much. Next, I'd like to introduce the discussant, Dr.
Yelena Janjigian from Memorial Sloan Kettering, to share her
perspectives on these results.
Good morning and thank you for the opportunity to discuss this important
abstract.
These are my disclosures.
And of course,
role of MSI varies across tumor types.
We're here to discuss gastric and gastroesophageal
cancer, where the rate of MSI tumors is approximately
10% in early stage, which is the disease we're discussing
today, and 3% in metastatic. Overall, these patients have
excellent prognosis, so many of them would be
cured with surgery alone. So why are we discussing this
option? And this important study today we're discussing will
be the potential to replace surgery and
non-operative management, which is critical.
Can early dual checkpoint blockade replace surgery in MSI high
gastric cancer? So what we saw today is that after three months of
therapy with durvalumab and a single dose of tremelimumab, we
achieved 71% complete response clinically,
94% progression-free survival, and 100% overall
survival, although the follow-up is short.
And most importantly, 70% of patients were able to go
without surgery, which is potentially life altering.
Gastrectomy, we can all agree, is a life-altering operation.
Where are we currently in the paradigm for this disease?
Well, Matterhorn study in the last year changed practice for
all comers, including MSS and MSI tumors, demonstrating
a survival benefit for perioperative chemoimmunotherapy
in early stage esophageal and gastric cancer.
More importantly, pathologic complete response does translate to
survival benefit, and so this is an important factor to consider as you're
interpreting the study. And for all comers, the complete
pathologic response is approximately 19% with anti-PD-1 plus
FLOT, and the major pathologic response is approximately
seen in 30% of patients.
So what about PD-1 blockade alone?
Importantly, we know that non-operative management is already included and
guidelines supported across several guidelines, including NCCN, but
the response rate varies by tumor type.
Of course, mismatch repair is a pan-tumor
biomarker, but when you're treating with rectal cancer versus
gastroesophageal cancer, the complete response rate to anti-PD1 alone is
quite variable. And for our disease, unfortunately,
60% of patients still needed surgery if you were to
pursue a durvalumab, for example,
aloneSingle versus dual neoadjuvant
blockade is an important question, and what appears to be that dual checkpoint
blockade will be important and required if you will be
approaching chemotherapy-free
approach to achieve organ preservation in gastroesophageal cancer.
We need CTLA-4 here to expand and
reactivate tumor-specific immunity.
And as you see here, again, inter-trial comparison, but the
dostarlimab arm
group had a similar
number of gastroesophageal cancer patients, so it's helpful to see these
numbers. Response with dual checkpoint blockade that Alberto
just presented appears to be numerically better.
And again, there's 20%, roughly, increase in the complete
response rate if you add at least one dose of
CTLA-4.
So what are the aspects of the INFINITY study?
Of course, it's an academic study, and again, congratulations to the Gano group
for getting this done. It's a small study, short follow-up.
And of course, T4 tumors were excluded, because those are higher
risk and they may need more time to treatment.
But it's very elegant design and really adaptive, looking
at important biomarkers of predictive of response and
resistance.
So the most innovative aspect of this study is, of course, non-operative
management. And to be able to convince the patients and, of
course, the surgeons not to have an operation is a true
important effort of the multidisciplinary group.
So the traditional paradigm has been chemotherapy followed by surgery and adjuvant
therapy in this disease. The
newest paradigm is to add immunotherapy,
and then the risk adaptive paradigm that you saw today
is perhaps to start with a short course of immunotherapy,
do response assessment, and then decide what to do next.
So the multimodal surveillance will need to reflect this
complex paradigm and to be able to adjust
to therapies along the way.
So the biomarker data from this study really helps
support and create a safety net
for non-operative management. And there is myeloid-rich
suppressive TME that is very important to assess, and of course,
circulating tumor DNA using newer assays will improve both
our sensitivity and specificity for predicting of response.
Unlike some other diseases, endoscopies are relatively easy to do, so
local assessment and serial biopsies and, of course, functional imaging
is very helpful for our cancers.
So how are we comparing then to
the difference across tumor types?
And of course, the toxicity profile in this regimen is quite
favorable. And as I mentioned, higher complete response rate really
suggests that anti PD-1 alone is not sufficient for our
disease. In fact, using chemoimmunotherapy,
it would be the only way to do anti PD-1 therapy alone, but
combined PD-1, CTLA-4 blockade would be useful.
So MSI tumors demonstrate the curative potential of
immunotherapy first in neoadjuvant setting, and you saw the
curves on the left
to look at the overall outcomes for, for
example, MSI high tumors using durvetrumab, two-year PFS
is 94%, while MSS surgery and
MSI surgery alone groups are reflected here.
But surgery alone, the two-year disease-free survival is 84%.
So what about operating on them first and then only
treating if you have MRD, so ctDNA positive setting?
Perhaps you would then avoid over-treating patients.
That's a question that was raised.
And looking on the right, this is a trial we presented
at ACR last year, that if you are
ctDNA positive in MSI tumors after resection, yes,
you could clear ctDNA with six months of, in this case, pembrolizumab,
and yes, you can improve on your
progression-free or disease-free survival.
At two years, the disease-free survival with adjuvant PD-1 therapy
was 92%. But despite initial
ctDNA clearance, 38% of patients,
eventually the ctDNA went up, and they
recurred. And again, highlighting that if you're MRD positive,
even in MSI setting, it's a very high-risk population, and six months of
adjuvant therapy is not sufficient.
More importantly, treating the tumor while the tumor is still in place in
neoadjuvant setting appears to be the really the critical
step to mounting anti-tumor response, avoiding surgery,
perhaps, and durably curing these patients.
So in conclusion, what we saw today is that dual immune checkpoint
blockade induces durable complete responses.
And again, congratulations to the Gano group
for this excellent study. Non-operative management was really the
breakthrough
demonstration of this approach to allow organ preservation.
And in the modern era, even for MSS tumor-specific
studies, if you're writing a consent form, the
patients expect to see non-operative option in there.
So that's a very modern approach to therapy.
Combination therapy appears to be necessary, and dual immune checkpoint blockade
does address some of that tumor heterogeneity that we see in our
disease, but not all. And future trials should integrate biomarkers,
response adaptive therapy, and personalized escalation or
de-escalation therapy. So the final take
point home is that early immunotherapy while
the tumor is still in place will redefine the current
standard for MSI high cancers, shifting from traditional
approaches of surgical approaches to non-operative
management.And the outstanding questions for our field is: Is
chemotherapy still necessary for MSI-high gastric and
gastroesophageal cancers? Because that's the gold standard with the Matterhorn
data, and we are awaiting the MSI subset from Matterhorn
FLOT durvalumab-treated cohort to see how it would
compare to the dual immune checkpoint cohort.
And can immunotherapy strategies truly replace surgery,
and how do we adapt to this regimen?
So in the past, we treated patients with surgery and chemotherapy.
Now we're doing FLOT plus anti-PD-1, and the future adaptive
therapy could involve dual immune checkpoint blockade first, then
your early response assessment. And if you are having high-risk
features and you're not seeing that you're on your way to complete
response, you could pivot to chemoimmunotherapy,
and eventually, I suspect some patients will still need surgery.
Thank you for your attention. It's really an amazing opportunity to
work with these bright talent across the globe,
and
congratulations again.
Great.
We're going to welcome some questions for five minutes of
discussion on this exciting data.
Happy to take questions from the audience,
but I can kind of get us started.
So I wanted to ask,
what do you think is the mechanism behind the need for only a single dose
of the tremelimumab, the anti-CTLA-4?
And do you think the timing of that dose plays a role in the
efficacy that we see with this addition?
Yeah. Thank you. This is a great question.
I would say that in our trial with tremelimumab and
durvalumab with a single dose of anti-CTLA-4, we
observed less adverse events
compared to the NEUMIPIGAR trial from the French group with
ipi/nivo.
Even for the duration of the neoadjuvant
treatment, the neoadjuvant part was the same.
So probably giving only one dose of the anti-CTLA-4
helped from that point of view.
This is a wonderful work. Congratulations.
I have a question is that clinical CR and pathological CR are
talking about different ideas, and they do not necessarily overlap
100% the same with each other. So how are you going to see the
differences
on these two different ideas of a group of patients? Thank you.
Yeah. Thank you. This is another good question.
We actually know that there is an unmatch
between clinical complete response and pathological complete
response from previous data from previous trial.
But what we should focus on now is
if we can rely on a multimodal clinical
complete response definition in order to substitute
the pathological complete response definition.
Patients with gastric cancer are usually going to see a surgeon
before they see a medical oncologist.
And a question for both of you, do you think that surgeons
are bought into this possible non-operative approach?
Yes, I think that's a very critical-- We're at an
inflection point where
in the non-academic, non-tertiary cancer centers, there's still a
steep learning curve. And
for
patients, but also the surgeons, the first
emotional reaction is this tumor needs to come out and it
belongs in the
bucket. But I have seen a really dramatic shift,
even just in the last year with the Matterhorn data, in the
approach to this tumor, and increasingly, the surgeons are
accepting. Even in Asia, where
most patients used to get surgery primarily first,
we're seeing increasing adaptation of neoadjuvant
therapy because of this emerging data, and there's now data
coming out of China also showing the same.
So I suspect within a year it's going to be even
wider accepted.
I actually have a question for both of you as well.
I was really struck by the ctDNA data and how well it
correlated with clinical
CR. How do you anticipate that being rolled out
into the real world and into clinical practice over the next year or two?
Yeah. Thank you for the question.
The best data of ctDNA
match with the clinical response were observed with the new panel,
with the plasma-only panel.
So we must wait for the validation for this panel.
And obviously, this will be a challenge for the clinical practice because we know
that not in all centers it's possible to do it.
That's why
for the moment, I would suggest this approach only in
big tertiary cancer centers.
And I would classify also that in MSS
gastroesophageal cancer, the data is not quite as strong.
I think MSI tumors in general lend themselves very well for
ctDNA monitoring, just because of the nature of the mutational burden.
And unfortunately, unlike what
Alberto says, I do see just rampant use
of these tools in the clinic, particularly
in a setting where you already exhausted all treatment options.
The patient clinically is fine. They completed all of their
neoadjuvant, adjuvant therapy, and then the surgeon sends a ctDNA and
it's positive. And then what? So unfortunately, I
call this morbid voyeurism . There's nothing to do about it
right now other than hope for a spontaneous clearance, and sometimes they
do. But it is a big problem.
Just as a follow-up to that,
in this particular case for this trial, are there plans
for extra monitoring or prolonged monitoring
with ctDNA? And if so, what are the plans for intervention?
So the non-operative management pathway ended after two years,
so we are not measuring it
anymore.
Okay. All right.
If there are no more questions, I think we'll move on to the next
set of speakers.
Thank you so much.
Okay. Our next speaker is Dr. Fabrice Barlisi
from Gustave Roussy
in University of Paris,
as well as,
the Jas Nagykun Szkolnok
Konyhatenye Geza Hospital Clinic, and I
apologize if I mispronounced that.
Good morning, everyone.
Dear chairmans, dear colleagues, thanks for giving us the
opportunity to present the interim results from the phase
2 MATIS trial of IPH5201, a
CD39 inhibitors combined with
durvalumab, a PD-L1 inhibitors, and platinum-based chemotherapy
in patients with resectable non-small cell lung cancer.
Here are my disclosures.
Then approximately 25% of patients with
non-small cell lung cancer are diagnosed at an early
stage, which is resectable and then potentially curable.
Based on the statistical and clinical
superiority of the combination of chemo-immunotherapy seen in many
phase three trials, neoadjuvant
chemo-immunotherapy has become the new standard of care
both in the US and in Europe.
In phase three studies with chemo combined with PD-1 or PD-L1
inhibitors, only 25% of patients
achieve pathologic complete response on
chemo-immunotherapy, which is associated with an increased
overall survival and can be considered as a surrogate marker.
Therefore,
developing next generation strategies to notably
improve the pathological complete response rate and then
the potential of cure of chemo-immunotherapy in
this setting is needed.
IPH5201 is a CD39
inhibitor.
As illustrated in this figure, CD39 is an
extracellular enzyme overexpressed in the tumor
microenvironment.
Upstream CD39 degrades
immunostimulatory extracellular ATP
released by dying cells into AMP, which is further
degraded into immunosuppressive
adenosine by downstream CD73.
Conversely,
blocking CD39 enhance dendritic cells
activation through ATP accumulations
and also restores T cell stimulation by
reducing adenosine levels.
As illustrated in the figure on the right, IPH5201
is a humanized Fc silent IgG1
inhibiting both membrane and soluble
CD39.
Preclinically, IPH5201
has demonstrated an improvement in antitumor activity
of durvalumab plus chemotherapy regimen, turning
anti-PD-L1 resistant tumors into sensitive one.
Clinically, IPH5201 as monotherapy
or in combination with durvalumab was well-tolerated
and pharmacodynamically active at the recommended phase two dose
of three thousand milligrams.
Therefore, we designed the MATIS study as an open label,
single arm, phase two study
evaluating IPH5201 in
combination with neoadjuvant chemotherapy
and perioperative durvalumab in
resectable early-stage non-small cell lung cancer.
The key eligibility criteria were patients with early-stage
resectable stage two and three, as defined by
multidisciplinary tumor board.
All PD-L1 TPS status can be included,
providing they were EGFR and ALK wild types.
Patients has to be, of course, previously untreated and in good shape with Eco
Performance Status of zero or one.
Patients are to provide with tumor biopsy before starting the
neoadjuvant part of the trial, especially in order to assess
PD-L1, CD39, and CD8
cell density.
The neoadjuvant part was based on the combination of
IPH5201 at a dosage of three thousand milligrams,
durvalumab at a dosage of fifteen hundred milligrams, and
chemotherapy as per guideline for four cycle every three
weeks.
Patient then underwent surgery,
and then in the adjuvant part may receive a combination of
IPH5201 and durvalumab for up to 12
cycles every four
weeks.The primary endpoint of the
study was the pathological complete response rate,
safety, EFS, DFS, overall survival, feasibility of the
surgery, major pathological response, overall response rate,
PK, and anti-drug antibodies were secondary endpoints.
The trial was designed to approach the rate of
pathological complete response based on this combination,
and 70 patients has to be included.
An interim analysis was planned after 20 and 40 patients.
I am presenting here the clinical results of the second interim analysis
on 40 patients at the data cutoff of December
2025.
The trial started recruitment in June 2023 and recruited patients in
France, Hungary, Poland, Greece, and USA.
The baseline characteristics of the patients were classical for lung cancer
patients populations, with two-third of male patients in
good shape, patients with tumor with PD-L1
expression of more than 1% in 70% of the cases,
a good balance between stage two and stage three, a balance for the
histology between adenocarcinoma and squamous cell carcinoma,
and for the backbone chemotherapy, two-third of the patients receive a
carboplatin-based chemotherapy and 60%
a pemetrexed-based chemotherapy.
Seventy-five patients were screened, and 40 were enrolled.
All these 40 patients receive at least one cycle of
neoadjuvant
combination of IPH501, travilumab, and
chemotherapy. Two patients received only one cycle,
two patients received two cycles, three patients received three
cycles, and all the remaining 33 patients received the four
planned cycles.
Thirty-five patients underwent surgery.
Five patients had no surgery. One patient was disqualified
by the surgeon. One patient had an inadequate
lung function, one consent withdrawn, and two patient has
a progressive disease before surgery.
The intention to treat populations included all of the patients, and at the time
of the data cut-off, 32 patients were in the adjuvant part of
the study.
If you look at the safety, an adverse event occur in
97% of the patients,
of grade three in 55% of the patient, which was drug
related in 32% of the case. The severe adverse
event was reported in 35% of the patients, and
unfortunately, one patients died due to a
postoperative pneumonia.
The type of adverse event occurring in more than 15% of the cases
were mainly related to the general status, asthenia,
weight decrease, decreased appetite,
GI adverse event, constipation,
nausea, and to hematological
toxicity related to chemotherapy.
If we look more specifically of the treatment-emerging adverse event
occurring in at least 10% of the patients related at least
to IPH5201, asthenia, arthralgia,
hyponatremia, and thrombocytopenia were the most
frequent.
Regarding the efficacy,
the overall response rate was 62.5%,
with three patients reaching a complete response and 22
patients reaching a partial response,
meaning 55% of the patients.
Regarding the surgery, 87.5% of the
patients underwent surgery.
The majority of the patients underwent surgery within
the 40 planned days after the completion of the neoadjuvant
treatment.
Subjects for whom surgery was delayed were delayed for logistic
reasons, one investigator decision, and three adverse events.
As a result of the surgery, an L0 resection was reached for the
majority of the patients operated in
88.6% of the cases.
Regarding our primary endpoint of efficacy, the pathological
complete response rate was
27.5% in the intention-to-treat
population with a major pathological response in
32.5% of the case.
Interestingly, there was an improved pathological complete response
rate
based on the PD-L1 tumor expression, and especially in patients
with PD-L1 expression of more than 1%, the pathological complete
response reached 35.7%, and for
patient with tumor with more than 50% of PD-L1
expression, the pathological complete response rate was
50%.
As of the mechanism of action of the IPH5201,
we looked at the CD39 cell density in the tumor
specimen of the MATIS study.
You can see here that CD39 expression
is
seen in
the tumor stroma. And here you have examples of
different cell density from a specimen from the MATIS
study. On the left, you can see a weak CD39 cell
density, in the middle, medium cell density, and strong cell
density on the right.
Interestingly, it was demonstrated that high expression of CD39 in the tumor
stroma was associated with poor recurrence-free survival rate
at five years. And conversely, high expression of CD39,
CD103, and CD8 positive T-cells in the tumor
predict improved recurrence-free survival.
And indeed, when we looked at the specimen in the MATIS
studyHigher baseline CD39 positive
cell density and CD8 positive cell density
was higher in patients reaching major pathological
response or complete pathological response.
It was true both for CD39 cell density in the tumor
and also CD8 cell density in the tumor at
baseline.
Interestingly, there was no correlation between
CD39 cell density in the tumor and the
PD-L1 cell expression.
In conclusion, MATISSE is the first clinical study to show the
feasibility and the preliminary activity of
preoperative CD39 blockade by
IPH5201 in combination with platinum-based
chemotherapy and the PD-L1 inhibition with
durvalumab for patients with early-stage resectable
non-small cell lung cancer. With the majority of patients
reaching surgery, 87.5% of the patients,
the safety profile, which was comparable to what we know from
preoperative combination of platinum-based chemotherapy and
durvalumab, and a promising overall pathological complete
response rate of 27.5% in the
intention-to-treat population.
Of course, it is important to try to predict the response to the
combination of the IPH5201 and durvalumab.
This response may be related both to the PD-L1 expression
status, with 37.5% and 50% of
the patients achieving pathological complete response when
the tumor expressed PD-L1 expression in more than 1% and
50% of the cells, respectively.
CD39 expression
is as a potential emerging biomarker trending to higher
intratumoral density in patients reaching pathological
complete response or major pathological response.
Therefore, MATISSE is paving the way for CD39 or more largely
adenosine pathway inhibition in early stage non-small cell lung cancer,
and MATISSE continues with the recruitment of PD-L1 of more than
1% only patients to further enrich the data set.
With that, I would like to thank all of the patients and the families
and the investigators, experts, and site staffs who participated in the study,
AstraZeneca for the financial support, and iNet Pharma, who is the sponsor of
the study, and I would like to thank you for your attention.
Thank you very much, Dr. Barlesi.
So to discuss this abstract is Dr. Tina Cascone
from UT
MD Anderson Cancer Center in Houston.
Thank you, co-chairs. Good morning.
I would like to thank the conference chairs and the scientific committee for
the invitation to discuss the interim analysis results of
the MATISSE trial, which is exploring whether
blocking CD39 could be an important
strategy in perioperative care for resectable lung
cancer.
Here you have my disclosures.
So my discussion will focus on three main aspects.
First, the biological rationale and mechanism of action of
anti-CD39 therapy in non-small cell lung cancer, strengths and
limitations of MATISSE, and how these results fit
into the current perioperative immunotherapy landscape for resectable lung
cancer.
In the past few years, the treatment landscape for select patients with
resectable non-small cell lung cancer has evolved
enormously.
Neoadjuvant, perioperative, and adjuvant chemoimmunotherapy-based
strategies have become standard of care, and several Phase
III trials of neoadjuvant and perioperative I-O have
consistently shown an improvement in event-free survival, with
hazard ratios in the range of 0.58 to 0.68
with emerging survival benefit.
However, despite this progress,
long-term outcomes for this population of patients remain suboptimal.
Even with modern regimens, five-year EFS rate is approximately
50%, which clearly highlights the need for more effective
and personalized treatments and better biomarkers to guide therapy.
MATISSE is a Phase II multicenter, open label, single
arm study, evaluating anti-CD39 therapy with
IPH5201 in combination with neoadjuvant chemotherapy and
perioperative durvalumab in patients with early-stage resectable
non-small cell lung cancer. So I would like to congratulate Dr.
Barlesi and colleagues for undertaking this effort
and for discussing these findings with me in advance of this
conference.
So I think to understand MATISSE, we need to revisit the ATP
adenosine pathway. In the tumor microenvironment,
extracellular ATP is converted into
adenosine via the sequential action of two important
molecules, CD39 and CD73, which can be
expressed on tumor cells and immune cells.
Adenosine is an important immunosuppressive molecule.
It can inhibit immune cell function, can reduce cytokine
production, and can lead to an exhausted immune microenvironment.
IPH5201 is an humanized antibody that
blocks CD39, and by doing so, limits the conversion
of ATP into AMP. And so ultimately, we will
have reduced immunosuppression from adenosine with activation
of dendritic cells and increased T cell-mediated
cytotoxicity and tumor
control.The preclinical
rationale is robust. CD39 inhibition
synergizes with chemotherapy in vivo,
and the antitumor effect appears to be primarily mediated via
CD8 and CD4.
In preclinical models, the combination of CD39
inhibition with immunotherapy and with chemoimmunotherapy
leads to tumor eradication and improves survival.
MATISSE is a classic signal-seeking Phase II
trial with a design that allows to make rapid
go/no-go decisions for clinical development.
The primary endpoint is the pathological complete response in the resected tumor
specimen and sample regional lymph nodes.
The study has no power to make definitive comparison
or for formal hypothesis testing.
The design allows to estimate a PCR rate with an
acceptable level of accuracy and to identify
potential promising biological signals that can justify further
clinical development of novel agents.
As you heard, the target PCR rate was set at
40% in MATISSE
based on the benchmark of 25% with neoadjuvant chemoimmunotherapy in the
CheckMate 816.
The MATISSE population included patients with Stage 2, 3A disease.
Half of those are Stage 3, and I think it will be important to
dissect the nodal status of this population as we know that
perioperative immunotherapy can be beneficial for patients with Stage 3
and 2 and N1 and 2, and with single and multi-station N2
status.
The PD-L1 breakdown overall reflects the
distribution of expression of this marker that we have seen across the study.
Feasibility is a strength. Almost 85% of patients
received the full four cycles planned in the neoadjuvant setting
with high resectability rate, no cancellation of surgery due
to adverse events, which is important as the addition of a
novel agent did not compromise the surgical outcomes.
In MATISSE, the perioperative dropout rate is lower than what
we've seen with other perioperative trials. This is very encouraging.
Eighty percent of patients achieved the adjuvant phase of the study.
However, we have some limitation, limited sample size, and I think it will be
important to better understand the features and the elements of
completion of perioperative treatment.
The overall PCR rate with MATISSE was
27.5%. Looking at the PD-L1 subgroups,
8.3% in the PD-L1 negative population,
35.7% in the overall positive PD-L1
subgroup, and 50% in the PD-L1
high tumors. So clearly a signal in the PD-L1 high
population. When we compare these rates to the AEGEAN,
which used the backbone chemotherapy in durva, we see
that there is an apparent increase in the PCR rate
with MATISSE, but not all patient subgroups
benefited the same. So you can see that perhaps the impact in
MATISSE of IPH5201 is greater in
the PD-L1 high population. We need to be careful.
These are cross-trial comparisons with 40 patients in MATISSE as compared to
more than 740 patients in the AEGEAN.
However, if we broaden this cross-trial comparison,
the apparent increase of PCR rate with MATISSE,
especially if we include the CheckMate 707T perioperative strategy,
CheckMate 816 neoadjuvant,
it becomes less clear in the high PD-L1 population.
So
the question is: how does IPH5201 antitumor activity
compare to that of other inhibitors of the ATP adenosine
pathway tested in the perioperative setting for resectable lung cancer?
Well, oleclumab is an anti-CD73 human monoclonal
antibody that selectively binds to and inhibits
CD73, and by doing so, reduces the CD73 cell
surface expression, reduces extracellular adenosine production, and
promotes antitumor immunity. Preclinical data have been very encouraging
with oleclumab in mouse models and also
in the window of opportunity trial NEOCOAST in a
chemo-sparing neoadjuvant approach with oleclumab and durvalumab for patients with
resectable non-small cell lung cancer.
Perioperative oleclumab plus durvalumab and neoadjuvant
chemotherapy have been tested in the NEOCOAST-2
multi-arm platform study for patients with resectable non-small cell lung
cancer. And what we have seen in NEOCOAST-2 is that the overall
pathological complete response rate with perioperative oleclumab, durvalumab, and
neoadjuvant chemo is 20.3%. However, not
all patient subgroups benefit equally.
In the PD-L1 negative population, the PCR rate with oleclumab is
16%, in the PD-L1 high, 31%. And
you can appreciate that the efficacy of
MATISSE, the IPH5201, appears to be having
greater magnitude in the PD-L1 high population.
And so perhaps these signals tell us that while we're looking at the small
numbers, targeting different components of the ATP
adenosine pathway might be more beneficial specifically for
particular type of subgroups. And so a more thoughtful
question, perhaps, is not just to compare anti-CD73 and
anti-CD39 therapy, but perhaps can we achieve greater
antitumor activity and immune stimulation by blocking the multiple
enzymatic steps of the ATP adenosine pathway?
Well, the IPH5301 is an anti-CD73
antibody that blocks enzyme activity of this molecule without
causing receptor internalization.
And so synergy of combining anti-CD39 and
anti-CD73 therapies could be achieved via reduced
resistance mechanisms and more robustimmune responses.
And that's where I strongly believe the translational and biomarker
study are critical. In MATIS, we have seen that the
CD39 cell density in baseline tumors
appears to be associated with pathological responses, although we are looking at
small numbers. And while we see an enrichment of the signal
in the PD-L1 high population with MATIS, we do not appreciate a clear
correlation and relationship between CD39 in tumor cells and
PD-L1 expression. And furthermore, in MATIS and in
NEOCOST too, the amount of CD8 T-cell
infiltrates in baseline tumor did not appear to correlate with
efficacy. That might tell us that perhaps single T-cell infiltration might
not be sufficient. What might possibly be more important is
colocalization of multiple markers that can
reflect better the nature of the immune microenvironment, and
specifically the spatial and the functional organization of these infiltrates.
Colocalization of CD39, CD103, and CD8 positive
T-cells in tumor nests of early stage non-small cell lung
cancer is associated with poor survival.
And this might reflect perhaps an active but immunosuppressed
immune microenvironment where combining anti-PD-L1 therapy with
blockade of multiple steps of the adenosine pathway
could be beneficial in a select subgroup of patients.
My takeaways, MATIS is a well-designed, biological
driven signal-seeking study that allows for rapid
go/no-go decision, perhaps specifically in the PD-L1 high
subset where the signal appears exciting.
However, it calls for an important need for
validation of biological drivers of efficacy to apply an
adenosine focused strategy with multi-step inhibition in select
subgroups. And also calls for the need of more robust,
integrated, and dynamic biomarker studies for better patient
selection. Thank you for your attention.
Thank you, Dr. Cascone. So this abstract and discussant
comments are open for discussion and questions.
I don't see anybody yet at the microphone. However, I do have a question.
So I was struck by obviously the CD39
potential as a biomarker.
And I'm interested in the patients that were PD-L1 low who
responded, whether or not they were high or had higher
levels of CD39.
Globally, we didn't find any correlation between the CD39 level and
the PD-L1 expression, which is something that I would say
is new, but of course needs to be confirmed in this study.
We have only 40
patients for the moment. I would say what we have in mind is the
fact that it is related because it's a regulation mechanism for
CD39 expression. But in this study, it was not the case.
I think that one of the main difference of this study compared to the
results what we have in mind is maybe the fact that we are talking about
early stage disease. And maybe all the mechanism of
resistance are not
in place in this early stage compared to advanced stage of the disease where
the majority of the studies and the results come from.
Very good. Thank you.
Yeah. What's the reason for the 3,000 milligram
need in the dose? And have you checked for
adenosine concentration in the surgical samples?
The 3,000 milligrams came from the phase one study that
has been conducted
in monotherapy and in combination with javaramab, and
the recommended phase two dose that is coming
from the phase one. For the moment, we don't have all the results of the
translational analysis that are ongoing, but of course we are looking to,
I would say,
different analysis, and here I presented only the baseline
analysis. But we will of course look at the surgical specimens.
And also we have a collection of blood
biomarkers that is on analysis for the moment.
It's a very large dose. There is a sink effect.
What's the reason you need so much antibody to block CD39?
I think
as far as I can explain this
point, it was linked to the fact that we want to inhibit both
the intratumoral but also the circulating CD39,
which may need a higher dosage than just inhibiting
the tissue CD39.
To the left.
Bill Dennis from NovaBridge. There's several studies that show the components of
the adenosine pathway are more highly expressed in non-squamous histology
than squamous. Did you see any differences in outcome in the non-squams,
and did you enrich for CD39 in better outcomes in that
population?
I think you're right. In this study, the rate of patients with
squamous histology is probably a little bit higher to what we expect in,
I would say, a worldwide population.
I don't have the results separated by the histological
subtypes. It's something, you're right, we have to look at.
Yeah, he actually stole my question.
But in a similar vein, do we think based on the
CD73 trials that there is some advantage in going after squamous
and providing better responses there?
Is there a signal that we've already seen there that suggests there's promise in
tackling that?
I think that for the NEOCOST-2 I can comment.
Perhaps even with the NEOCOST, which was really the window of opportunity
trial in a chemo-sparing regimen.
So there we don't have really the component of chemotherapy.
We saw signal overall across histologies.
And with the chemotherapy,
if you look at the overall population and you look at the breakdown by PD-L1,
then you don't see much difference.
But I think in the
NEOCOST-2, you definitely can
appreciateBetter signal in the
PL1 negative population, 16% as compared to 8.3%.
The numbers are too small to dissect whether that signal is driven by histology,
but that will be an important question for future studies.
Got you.
One thing that perhaps I wanted to add, Ryan, to your question, I think it will
be critical in the biomarker analysis to look at the
correlations of translational correlates, and not just as
a categorical response, PCR or MPR,
but as a continuous variables, Y of a residual viable tumor.
That will be critical to give us more of the wealth representation of the data.
Very good. Well, with that, I'd like to again thank Dr.
Barbiści and Dr. Cascone, for a wonderful session.
All right. Next, I'd like to welcome
Dr. Bruno Boccorni, Assistant Professor of Medicine
from Beth Israel Deaconess Medical Center and Dana-Farber in Boston.
He'll present preliminary results from a Phase 1 study of the
anti-CCR8 antibody in patients with advanced solid tumors.
Good morning.
On behalf of my co-authors, I would like to thank ACR for the
opportunity to present the preliminary results of the
Phase 1 first-in-human dose-escalation study
with the anti-CCR8 antibody, denicitug, in patients with
advanced solid cancers.
These are my disclosures.
So let me start with the rationale.
Regulatory T cells or Tregs are major
drivers of immunosuppression within the tumor microenvironment.
Their accumulation is associated with worse outcomes across
tumor types, and it represents one of
the main mechanisms of resistance to
checkpoint immunotherapy.
Now, the critical
rationale here is selectivity.
CCR8 is preferentially expressed on
intratumoral Tregs as compared to peripheral Tregs,
making it a very compelling immunotherapy target.
Denicitug, it's a monoclonal
antibody that's afucosylated and FC
engineered, specifically designed to maximize
antibody-dependent cellular cytotoxicity.
In preclinical models, the data has shown that
depletion of CCR8 positive intratumoral
Tregs
can enhance antitumor immune response and overcome
IO resistance.
So the objectives of this study were to
assess the safety and the preliminary
efficacy of denicitug in patients with advanced solid
cancers.
The study has two major components.
One, to evaluate denicitug as a monotherapy and in
combination with an anti-PD-1 inhibitor.
The focus of today's presentation will be the two monotherapy
cohorts, part A and part B.
Part A was a dose escalation that
enrolled 16 patients.
It started with an accelerated titration approach at
low dose levels, followed by an interval
3+3 design.
The doses ranged from one milligram to 100 milligrams
once every three weeks.
Part B was a paired tumor biopsy cohort that enrolled
an additional 41 patients to dose levels of 10
milligrams and above. That was the range that was predicted to be
pharmacologic active based on the part A
result.
Denicitug was given once every three weeks for up to one year,
unless the patients met criteria to discontinue therapy.
Key eligibility criteria included advanced solid
cancers with no remaining standard treatment
option available,
ECOG 0 to 2, and adequate organ function.
The primary endpoint of part A was safety,
and efficacy was an exploratory endpoint of both
parts.
And the data cutoff for this study was March 24th,
2026.
Across both cohorts, 57 patients were
enrolled,
and you can see that this was a heavily pretreated population with a median
of three prior lines of therapy,
and two-thirds of the patients had received prior PD-1 or
anti-PD-L1 therapy.
Tumor types were diverse, including non-small cell lung cancer,
gastric and gastroesophageal, gynecologic malignancies,
breast cancer, and head and neck squamous cell carcinoma.
At the time of data cut, the median time of
study was 20.7 weeks.
Now turning to safety.
This slide here provides a high-level overview of the treatment-emergent
adverse events.
The overall profile of denicitug was manageable.
Grade 3 and serious adverse events did occur but were generally
manageable with supportive care.
There were no dose-limiting toxicities reported in the dose
escalation portion.
Also importantly, there were no Grade 4 or 5
treatment-related adverse events across both
parts.Overall,
14% of the patients discontinued therapy due to an
adverse event.
Now, looking at the treatment-related adverse events
occurring in more than 5% of the patients,
skin rash and pruritus were the most common ones, followed
by diarrhea and fatigue.
As you can see here in red, grade three events were
uncommon across all categories.
This overall profile is consistent with the immunomodulatory mechanism
of action of Treg depletion.
Now moving to efficacy.
These are the Recist responses in the efficacy-evaluable population.
Confirmed partial responses were seen across different tumor
types, and a substantial number of additional patients
achieved stable disease.
Objective responses were seen in patients receiving denikitag
with a dose as low as 10 milligrams.
And please note these yellow marks that represent
prior use of anti-PD-1 and anti-PD-L1.
You see that this population is made up largely of patients who had
previous exposure to immunotherapy.
Now, in the bottom axis here, you see the
baseline CCR8 expression level for
each patient.
And you notice that both responders and
non-responders had a wide range of CCR8
expression,
including some undetectable levels in responders.
So at this stage, we are not able to draw clear
conclusions about the relationship between CCR8
expression and response.
But it is important, though, to
interpret this lack of correlation with caution.
Our data set's quite heterogeneous, with different tumor
types and several different prior lines of therapy.
Any of these variables could be influencing the picture.
Now that we are moving to a more homogeneous population,
we'll be better positioned to understand if CCR8
expression has a potential to serve as a biomarker for
response.
The efficacy summary.
In the efficacy-evaluable population of 52 patients,
denikitag monotherapy led to an objective response
rate of 8%
and a disease control rate of 46%.
This was a heavily pretreated population.
Responders had a median of six prior lines of
therapy,
and their responses were durable.
The median duration of response was
4.3 months, ranging up to 14.6
months.
Now, we put a lot of effort to try to
understand the immunobiological effects of denikitag.
So we assess pair baseline and on-treatment
biopsies of patients who were enrolled to Part B.
Following
two doses of denikitag,
we saw a marked depletion of the
CCR8 positive intratumoral Tregs
across all dose levels tested, 10 milligrams, 30, and
100 milligrams.
That you can see here in the left panel.
We also saw a concurrent expansion and
infiltration of CD8 effector T cells also
across all three dose levels,
you can see here in the right panel.
We saw similar trends in the peripheral blood, but the data is not
shown here today.
Now, let me show you this case that illustrates well
radiographic response and biomarker dynamics.
This is actually my patient.
She's a 78 years old woman with metastatic
non-small cell lung cancer.
Her disease is essentially PD-L1 negative
with TPS score less than 1%.
She had received five prior lines of treatment before going on
trial, including pembrolizumab-based combinations, and she
had progressed.
So she went on to receive denikitag at 10 milligrams every three
weeks, and she achieved a deep partial response,
you can see here in the CT scans, with major shrinkage of
both target and non-target lesions.
Her response lasted over 14 months.
This patient did have low-grade immune-mediated adverse
events. She had skin rash and pruritus, which I treated
successfully with topical steroids.
And here in the right panel, you see the H&E
stainings of her pair biopsies. And you can see that there was,
after two dose of denikitag, there was a significant increase
of the infiltration by immune cells before
treatment and after treatment. This was after two doses of
denikitag.
And the biomarker
data for this patient showed exactly what we saw in the larger
population. Denikitag monotherapy
led to a near-complete depletion of
CCR8 positive intratumoral Tregs just after two
doses.And a concurrent expansion of
CD8 effector T cells that you can see here on the right.
Quite robust expansion.
In conclusion, denikitag is pharmacologically
active at doses of 10 milligrams and above.
This was demonstrated through consistent and significant
depletion of CCR8 positive intra-tumoral Tregs
with a concurrent increase in effector T cells.
Anti-tumor activity was observed in heavily pre-treated
patients, including those who had previously received
anti-PD-1 and anti-PD-L1 therapy.
Denikitag monotherapy demonstrated a manageable safety
profile. The observed treatment-related
adverse events were consistent with immunomodulatory mechanism of
action of Treg depletion.
Together, this data supports the further evaluation of
denikitag both as a monotherapy and
in combination with other agents, including checkpoint inhibitors.
I would like to thank the patients and their families for
participation in the study,
to all co-investigators, the investigating sites, the study
team, and to the sponsor, Gilead Sciences.
And I'll be happy to take your questions. Thank you very much.
Next, I'd like to introduce the discussant, Dr.
Ignacio Garrido Laguna from the Moffitt Cancer Center, to
provide some perspectives and context for these results.
Good morning. I would like to thank the organizing committee and
our session chairs today for the opportunity to discuss this very
interesting abstract. I also want to thank Dr.
Boccorni for
answering my questions timely.
These are my disclosures.
The pipeline of drugs targeting CCR8 has expanded
rapidly. This includes a number of different
classes. The most common, monoclonal antibodies,
followed by small molecules blocking the receptor
or bispecifics. Not shown in this slide, we also
have antibody drug conjugates already in the clinic, as well
as some emerging preclinical data with radioligand
therapy.
On the right side, on the upper panel, you can appreciate how
most of these antibodies are non-fucosylated
to increase the antibody-dependent cellular
cytotoxicity via NK cells.
On the bottom panel, you can also appreciate how
several of these programs have already been discontinued,
highlighting some of the challenges we're facing.
As a target, CCR8 is expressed in
clonally expanding Tregs and restricted to tumor
tissues.
The percentage
of Tregs that express CCR8 range between
40% and 80% across different tumor types.
It is also important to note that different to CTLA-4
antibodies,
antibodies targeting CCR8 may provide a
better therapeutic index by sparing peripheral
Treg cell.
CCR8 expression has also been associated to worse
outcomes, both in patients with colorectal as well as lung
cancer.
The mechanism of cell death,
it's still a matter of debate. We have plenty
preclinical evidence suggesting that this is related
to Treg depletion via NK cells,
and that blocking the receptor will not impact
the accumulation of Tregs within the tumor.
However, we have some emerging evidence suggesting also a role for these
molecules blocking the receptor, perhaps by switching the
immunophenotype of these Tregs to a less
immunosuppressive phenotype.
The tumor microenvironment, it's a highly redundant and
interconnected system
with multiple players contributing to T cell exhaustion.
So from that perspective, we can hypothesize
that perhaps strategies focusing on targeting a single
node are going to have limited activity as single agents.
Now let's look at the study beautifully presented today by Dr.
Boccorni, and we're going to look into this study
analyzing safety profile, efficacy,
biomarkers, dose selection, and future steps.
As you just heard, this was a dose escalation
study with three dose levels after the
initial accelerating titration.
Dose levels at 10,
30, and 100 milligrams given Q through three weeks.
This was followed by a paired tumor biopsy cohort
with 41 patients enrolled with different tumor types.
Looking at safety, as you just heard, this drug has a
manageable safety profile,
with the most common adverse events being rash, pruritus, and
diarrhea.
These adverse events are related to the mechanism of action of the drug,
as CCR8 positive Tregs are also
present in barrier organs like the
skin.It's also important to remember that the
expression of this
CCR8 positive T-regs might be context
dependent.
Here, I'm showing you preclinical work in mice
where CCR8 was knocked out
in the context of cardiac ischemia.
That led to excessive inflammation
resulting in decreased ejection fraction and shorter survival
in those animals.
As you just heard, there were no dose-limiting toxicities.
There were no infusion reactions, and this is different to the data you
heard presented on Saturday with AMG
355 by Dr. Fakih.
Treatment-related adverse events led to treatment
discontinuation in 14% of the patients.
This is the molecule that has the highest incidence of RAS
among CCRC antibodies that we have seen presented.
So it's important that we understand the RAS with a little bit
more granularity. What is the time of onset?
What are the characteristics? Are there any risk factors to develop this
RAS? How was the RAS managed? Did they need to implement
prophylaxis at some point? Did RAS require dose
interruption, dose modification?
And finally, although we cannot look into that given the very
few responses, as data builds, it will be interesting to
understand if there's any association between RAS and response.
From efficacy perspective,
as a single agent, this molecule has modest
activity with a response rate of only 8%.
And I want to bring to your attention the flat dose
response for efficacy, with three partial responses
seen at the lowest dose level at three milligrams and one PR seen
at the highest at 100 milligrams.
You can also appreciate at the bottom how the duration of
responses are short at only four months.
Of course, granted, this is a heavily pretreated patient population, as you heard
from Dr. Bokhari.
In contrast to other CCR8 antibodies, there was
no correlation with CCR8 expression
and response. But again, we have limited number of responses.
The effort at collecting
biopsies needs to be highlighted.
They were able to collect biopsies in over 60% of the
patients in this biopsy cohort. I think that's remarkable knowing the
complexity in a heavily pretreated patient population.
They show nice depletion of
T-regs, but I want to bring to your attention that
there is, again, the dose
respond is flat. You get nearly complete elimination of
T-regs at 10 milligrams and no
difference with what we see at the highest dose level.
Perhaps
the one concern I will have, despite this significant T-reg
depletion, there's very modest increase
in activated CD8 T cells. And again,
really no significant different from what we can appreciate
on the plot between 10 and 100, perhaps
only significant for the 30 milligram dose level.
This modest increase in T cell despite
T-reg depletion suggests that perhaps the complex
tumor microenvironment again is contributing from multiple players
to that T-reg
or to that phenotype of exhausted T cells.
Now the main issues on this study,
they do have non-clinical data that suggests activity in a
colorectal model, pancreatic model,
but they haven't shown us any PK data to show
linearity on the PK that we get higher exposure
with higher doses and to try to correlate that with
responses.
We have beautiful PD data, but again, we
have this flat dose response that doesn't help us much with dose selection.
We have
learned that the drug is well-tolerated,
but perhaps some of these side effects are going to limit some of the
potential pathways for development of this compound.
For instance, in MSI stable colorectal, or with the
rapidly changing landscape in pancreatic cancer in
combination with multi RAS inhibitor.
That doesn't seem a combo that will be tolerated given the high incidence of
RAS.
Again, modest efficacy with a flat dose response
also no helping us with the dose selection.
So where to go next?
CCR8 is highly expressed in head and neck,
gastric, colorectal, lung.
So we could envision a pathway where we focus on
developing these drugs in indications where there's already an approval
of a PD1 inhibitor. And there's randomized trials ongoing
in different countries combining CCR8 antibodies
and PD1 based on promising response rates shown in this disease.
But we could also go to diseases where there's no PD1 inhibitors
approved. Prostate cancer, we have a trial already planned with a
combination in that setting. Pancreatic cancer, where we have preclinical
evidence of activity and one of these agents that have shown a remarkable
response rate of 22%.
Importantly, with RAS inhibitors, we see responses, but they tend to
have limited duration. And we know that
to extend the duration of responses, we need contributions from the immune
system. So again, we can envision combinations with
a RAS inhibitor with a better scheme profile, like an allele-specific
inhibitor.
Just to finalize
In terms of safety profile, it's consistent with the mechanism of
action. There were no unexpected signals.
Clinical activity is modest. That could be expected.
These drugs will need to be developed in combination.
They didn't see any correlation with CCR8 expression and
responses, but as highlighted, these are small numbers and other drugs have
shown that correlation. We don't have any info on PK or
PD. We do have beautiful PD data, but it does not help us
inform the dose selection. And next development steps are
pending selection of the right dosage and indications.
And I'm going to stop there. I appreciate all your
attention. Thank you.
Okay. We're happy to take some questions from the audience. We can start here.
Hi. Thank you. Great presentation.
I was just curious, could you comment on what was the
duration from the last PD-1 exposure, especially in the patients that you've seen
responses? And the second question is,
excellent biopsy data. Have you also looked at more
downstream immune reprogramming with respect to myeloid
repolarization?
Great question. I don't know from the top of my mind the
previous duration of interval between PD-1
and enrollment on study for those responders, but
we can try to get this information for you offline.
And to answer your second question, yes.
So we got a lot of efforts. We got pair
biopsies of 26 patients out of the 41
that we enrolled. It's a lot of work.
We just showed the highlights of the
primary objective of the drug, which was depletion of CCR8
positive intratumor Tregs, and downstream of that, increase the expansion
of the CD8 effector T cells. Yes, we are doing other
transcriptome analysis, investigating cytokine changes in the tumor
microenvironment. The data is not finalized yet, but will be
soon.
Thank you.
Quick question. So
related to pharmacokinetics,
CCR8 depletion was visualized
using antibodies to non-overlapping epitope of CCR8?
Sorry, what was the question?
So you measured CCR8 levels in
biopsies-
Mm-hmm.
Using antibody to an independent CCR8 epitope?
I don't know if I have the answer to your question.
I didn't run the experiments. I was the clinician in the clinical
trial, but I can also try to get this information for you.
Because most likely you have blocked epitope and-
Yeah.
If you don't have an overlay.
Yeah. I just have a question about the Treg depletion data.
I think the discussant rightly pointed out that the maximum
inhibition looked independent of dose.
Yeah.
But I also noticed the baseline level seemed to vary a lot.
In fact, almost with dose, it went up with dose.
Yeah.
I wonder if you have an explanation for what's going on there.
We look at that. We couldn't have an explanation.
This is a very heterogeneous population.
It is possible that the representation of tumor between the three
dose levels was different. But we did notice
that the baseline
CCR8 Tregs in the 10 milligrams, 30,
and 100 milligrams cohort were increased.
I think was just random because of distribution of tumor types.
But the point you said, even at 10 milligrams, there's a near complete
depletion of the Tregs even at the lowest dose that we tried.
Thank you.
This will be our last question.
Thank you for your work. Sorry, I have more than one question.
But you didn't report
on reduction of Tregs in the
periphery. And very simply,
as you know, CD16 polymorphisms are
associated with the activity of
depletion.
And it's certainly likely that this is not due to NK
cells, but CD16 positive myeloid cells
that are likely at the tumor site. So that would be
my last question, is whether you evaluated
myeloid cells in these particular patients.
I do not have that information. I don't know if the
sponsor's looking into that. We did see depletion
of peripheral blood Tregs in the
blood, but we just didn't bring this data today.
And polymorphisms of CD16?
I am not-
Very easy to measure.
I am not aware of that data.
All right. Well, thank you Dr. Pokorny and Dr.
Laguna for a fantastic discussion. Great data.
Awesome. Thank you.
Thank you.
Okay, and we're going to move on to our last two set of speakers.
So it's a pleasure to introduce Archana Balan,
who is from the Sidney Kimmel Comprehensive Cancer Center at
Johns Hopkins University.
Good morning. I'm Archana Balan. I'm a graduate student at the School of
Biomedical Engineering at Johns Hopkins University.
And on behalf of my co-authors, I'm delighted to present the translational
findings from the HUDSON clinical trial focusing on
multi-omic analysis of immunotherapy resistance in non-small cell lung
cancer.
I have no financial disclosures.
Immune checkpoint inhibitors have significantly improved outcomes in patients with
non-small cell lung cancer. However, resistance to anti-PD-1 or
PD-L1 therapy still remains a major clinical challenge.
Immunotherapy resistance is broadly classified into two groups:
primary resistance, where there is no measurable response to immunotherapy,
typically within six months, and acquired resistance, where there's an initial
clinical benefit of at least six months followed by disease progression.
Previous studies have identified several molecular features associated with
immunotherapy resistance, including KRAS/SDK11
co-mutations that promote an immunosuppressive tumor microenvironment,
as well as inactivating mutations in genes such as KEAP1, V2M,
JAK1, JAK2,
PTEN, and β-catenin,
which confer tumor immune exclusion or loss of responsiveness
to interferon gamma signaling. In tandem, cancer cells
also evade immune surveillance in an
inflamed yet permissive tumor microenvironment where chronic interferon
gamma stimulation may render cancer cells resistant to immune
checkpoint blockade.
Despite these insights, therapeutic breakthroughs to prevent or overcome
immunotherapy resistance have been limited, in part due to our limited
understanding of its drivers.
To investigate mechanisms of immunotherapy resistance, we leveraged the screening
population from the HUDSON trial, which was a phase two,
multi-drug, biomarker-directed umbrella study in patients with
advanced non-small cell lung cancer who had progressed on prior
anti-PD-L1 therapy.
The HUDSON screening population represented a unique aggregation of
951 immunotherapy-resistant patients with non-small cell lung
cancer. Patients were divided into two groups, that of primary
resistance, defined by disease progression within 24 weeks, and acquired
resistance, defined by disease progression after 24 weeks.
One of the exploratory endpoints of the HUDSON trial was to identify
genomic, transcriptomic, and immune features that distinguish primary
from acquired resistance in the screening population, which we will review
today.
To our knowledge, this cohort represents the largest cohort of
immunotherapy-resistant non-small cell lung cancer, comprising over
1,800 biospecimens from 951 patients
with advanced non-small cell lung cancer who had received prior immunotherapy.
As shown in the sample disposition schema on the left, we performed
comprehensive multi-omic analysis, including targeted tumor
and circulating tumor DNA next-generation sequencing,
bulk and single-cell RNA sequencing, peripheral T-cell receptor
sequencing, and PD-L1 expression.
Tumor genomic profiling was performed on unmatched pre- and post-IO
samples, whereas all other data modalities were derived from post-IO
samples procured at the time of IO resistance.
We first hypothesized that immunotherapy resistance is
in part genomically wired and examined various
aggregate features, as well as distinct mutations and
co-mutations.
Tumor mutation burden was significantly higher in the acquired resistance group,
largely driven by an increased number of subclonal mutations in post-IO
tumors, suggesting greater intratumoral heterogeneity.
Notably, ctDNA levels were lower in the acquired resistance group when
compared to primary resistance, suggesting lower systemic disease
burden.
These initial findings suggested that while there seems to be a window of
opportunity to intervene and prevent acquired resistance, an
in-depth understanding of the genomic complexity of resistant tumors
would be critical to inform effective therapeutic strategies.
Given the immunomodulatory effects of genomic instability and
unresolved DNA damage, we assessed differences in
genomic scarring between primary and acquired resistance groups.
We found an increased number of large-scale transitions and telomeric allele
imbalances in post-IO tumors across both acquired
and primary resistance groups when compared to unmatched pre-IO
samples.
Similarly, a composite estimate of homologous recombination deficiency,
derived by aggregating large-scale transitions, telomeric allele imbalance,
and genome-wide loss of heterozygosity, was also significantly
enriched in post-IO tumors across both resistance groups.
These findings suggest that persistent genomic instability may be part of
the tumor escape circuit that drives IO resistance.
Motivated by previous findings, we hypothesized that differential
activation of cancer hallmarks through genomic alterations paints the
landscape of immunotherapy resistance across our study cohort.
In this plot, each column represents an individual patient ordered first
by resistance type, acquired, then primary, and further grouped by
tumor tissue sampling time point, pre and post-IO.
This is precisely what we found and are showing here at a high level.
The landscape highlights that putative genomic determinants of immunotherapy
resistance span multiple pathways and cancer hallmarks,
including alterations in genes involved in proliferative
signaling, cell cycle regulation, DNA damage repair,
chromatin regulation, and dedifferentiation.
Importantly, each altered hallmark was largely non-overlapping across
patients, indicating that acquired immunotherapy resistance is
driven by diverse genomic mechanisms.
We will review these in detail, but again, from a broader perspective,
our analysis identify additional candidate genomic features in
patients who do not harbor the canonical drivers of resistance,
indicating a larger and complex immunotherapy resistance
landscape than previously
described.Focusing more closely on
genomic alterations known to confer IO resistance, we found that
around 40% of patients with acquired resistance,
as well as primary resistance, harbored alterations in at least one
canonical driver of resistance, mainly involving STK11,
KEAP1, and KRAS STK11 co-mutations.
While PTEN, JAK1, and JAK2 mutations were detected, they were
less frequent across both resistance groups.
I particularly want to emphasize the frequencies and
fractions shown at the bottom of the plot, which are the aggregate
mutation frequencies computed within the landmark of interest
within pre and post-IO samples in the acquired and primary resistance
groups.
Notably, we identified a cluster of mutations affecting genes involved
in genome maintenance that were increased in frequency in post-IO
tumors in the acquired resistance group.
As shown here, alterations involved in genes
involved in cell cycle regulation, mismatch repair, and
chromatin regulation were enriched in post-IO tumors in the
acquired resistance group, suggesting that genomic instability may
emerge under the selective pressure of immune checkpoint blockade.
As oncogenic signaling may drive tumor immune escape, we next assess
differential enrichment of mutations aggregated
across genes involved in proliferative signaling.
Interestingly, we found that mutations in the FGF and mTOR
pathways were enriched in the acquired resistance group,
further suggesting that potentially indicating a signaling
pathway rewiring in the acquired resistance group that may equip cancer
cells with a fitness advantage and may enable them to evade
immune surveillance.
Alterations in genes involved in lineage differentiation and
neuroendocrine dedifferentiation in the acquired resistance group
were predominantly detected in the post-IO tumors,
again suggesting that lineage plasticity may drive immunotherapy resistance in
a subset of cases.
To assess the differential enrichment of distinct genotypes between the
resistance groups, we evaluated multiple
alteration categories based on recurrence and functional consequence.
After adjusting for tumor mutation burdens and passenger mutations,
significant findings here are shown with an asterisk.
Tumors in the acquired resistance group were enriched for driver mutations
in FGF10, Rictor, NRAS,
MSH3, MSH6, and RBM10,
suggesting coordinated activation of proliferative signaling,
along with disruption of DNA damage repair and RNA splicing.
Interestingly, we also observed an enrichment of DNMT3A
mutations, potentially indicating the likely expansion of
myeloid tumor-infiltrating clonal hematopoiesis
population.
In contrast, tumors with primary resistance were enriched for driver
mutations in STK11, APC, NMIC, and
NF2.
The differential enrichment of genotypes between the two resistance groups further
demonstrates that acquired and primary resistance are in part driven
by distinct molecular programs.
Focusing on the acquired resistance group and comparing pre and post-IO
tumors, we observed that post-IO tumors were enriched for
CDK4 driver and RB1 inactivating mutations,
again suggesting that cell cycle deregulation may equip
cancer cells with a fitness advantage and drive immune escape.
We also observed an enrichment of EP300 and KDM6A
alterations, suggesting chromatin dysregulation in post-IO
tumors, along with an increased density of SMARCA4 and
LMIC mutations, suggesting lineage plasticity and dedifferentiation.
Together, these findings suggest that cell cycle deregulation,
lineage plasticity, and epigenetic remodeling may be critical
features of acquired resistance that may be therapeutically leveraged.
We next expanded our analysis to the transcriptomic level, starting
with gene set enrichment analysis of bulk RNA sequencing data
comparing acquired and primary resistance in post-IO,
pre-Hudson treatment tumors. We observed an enrichment
of gene expression programs associated with interferon gamma
signaling, inflammatory response, and TNF alpha via NF
kappa beta signaling, suggesting persistent
interferon gamma stimulation and chronic
inflammatory signaling that may mediate immune dysfunction.
Notably, the enrichment of epithelial to mesenchymal transition
program was predominant in the acquired resistance group, as shown as
an aggregate on the left and at a sample level on the right,
suggesting an interplay between cell states,
TME remodeling, tumor escape, and immunotherapy
resistance.
We next asked whether the differential enrichment of gene expression programs was
reflected on overall survival, modeling overall survival as a
continuous variable rather than binarizing it, and
looking at gene sets that were consistently associated with longer overall
survival.
EMT was associated with shorter overall survival, together with
MYC targets and metabolic reprogramming pathways such as oxidative
phosphorylation and glycolysis.
These findings suggested that the evolutionary cost of immunotherapy-acquired
resistance may be mediated by cell plasticity and metabolic
reprogramming that may be therapeutically leveraged.
We next incorporated single-cell analysis to bring further resolution to the
transcriptomic data, focusing again on post-IO tumors from
the acquired and primary resistance groups.
Through clustering of over 200,000 cells derived from 61 samples, we
identified nine distinct clusters, including epithelial and
immune cell clusters, as shown in the left panel.
We will focus on the seven CD8 positive T cell clusters shown in the middle panel,
particularly the tissue-resident memory and stem-like
populations.As well as the five distinct epithelial
subclusters shown on the right panel, and particularly the EMT-engaged and
pluripotent stem-like populations.
When analyzing the CD8 positive T cell clusters, we identified three
tissue-resident memory or TRM T cell clusters marked by a high
expression of TRM genes such as ITGAE and ITGA1,
alongside a stem-like precursor CD8 positive
cluster marked by the expression of TCF7 and IL7R.
The three TRM clusters harbored tumor-reactive gene expression
programs, with TRM3 differentially enriched for acquired
resistance, indicating
persistent and partially effective antitumor immune response.
Notably, we identified a pre-exhausted stem-like phenotype
across the T cell subsets, which was differentially enriched for
acquired resistance. These findings likely indicate the enrichment
of hyperfunctional T cell states, echoing the signal seen in the bulk
transcriptomic data where acquired resistance was associated
with an inflamed yet dysfunctional immune state.
Turning to the five distinct epithelial subclusters, we will focus on the EMT
engaged, the pluripotent stem-like, and the
TUFT-like or neuroendocrine-like clusters.
We found a clear enrichment of the pluripotent stem-like population in the
acquired resistance samples, as shown in the middle panels, further
supporting the role of lineage plasticity as a driver of acquired
resistance.
Gene set enrichment analysis within the epithelial subsets revealed an
enrichment of EMT and TGF-beta signaling in the acquired
resistance group in the EMT engaged cluster, along with the
downregulation of antigen presentation.
You can appreciate the differential enrichment of interferon gamma
signaling in the AT2-like cluster and xenobiotic
metabolism in the mucinous cluster, likely
indicating intratumoral heterogeneity and convergent
evolution of cancer clones as a substrate of immune escape.
In conclusion, to our knowledge, we analyzed the largest cohort of
IO resistance in non-small cell lung cancer,
compiled with more than 900 patients from the
HUDSON phase 2 clinical trial.
We identified distinct genomic features associated with acquired resistance,
along with genomic alterations in pathways such as cell cycle, DNA
damage repair, and dedifferentiation.
Whereas genomic instability was a shared feature between the two resistance
groups. Acquired resistance was associated with upregulation
of epithelial to mesenchymal translation transition, a
downregulation of antigen presentation,
an increased density of pluripotent stem-like cell states, and
metabolic reprogramming, which together orchestrate the convergent
evolution of IO resistance.
The immune infiltrate at the time of acquired resistance showed
dysfunctional interferon gamma signaling, along with an enrichment of
hyperfunctional T cell states.
Overall, our findings suggest that IO resistance is multifactorial,
as cancer cells acquire a fitness advantage through differential activation of
cancer hallmarks, cell states, and immune escape, pointing
towards convergent evolution.
The evolutionary cost of IO resistance may reveal actionable
vulnerabilities that require personalized combination strategies
in the post-IO setting to help overcome IO resistance.
Finally, I would like to thank all the patients and their caregivers, as well as
the investigators and site staff who participated in the HUDSON study.
I would also like to acknowledge my mentor, Dr.
Anagnostou from the Johns Hopkins School of Medicine.
Thank you very much for your attention.
Thank you very much. To discuss this abstract, it's a pleasure
to introduce Dr. Michele Mau from the University of
Siena, Siena, Italy.
Thank you. Good morning.
Thank you to ACR for allowing me to
discuss this very
interesting, and I must say, complex, as we have been discussing before
with the author's
paper.
Immunotherapy resistance, of course, as you all know, is a
crucial issue in the clinic, both in terms of primary
resistance and in terms of
acquired resistance. So
the dissection
of the mechanisms that can be
relevant for primary, and as we have seen,
acquired resistance,
is a topic of paramount importance
when we need to treat our
patients in general.
This paper we have just heard, I won't go with you through the
results,
is in my opinion very interesting because
it is a large cohort of
IO-resistant patients that were enrolled
in the Hudson trial afterwards.
Here are my disclosures.
As I said, those are the patients, over 900
patients that have been
screened, have failed IO, and have been
screened for the Hudson
trial.
The landscape characterization of those patients
is genomic transcriptomic immune architecture
distinguishing, that was the endpoint, primary and
acquired resistance prior to entering
patients into the Hudson
trialWe have just seen this slide,
exploratory analysis were done at
baseline in the Hudson bio specimens,
and
it is important to stress that the genomic profiling
was done in unpaired
tumor samples, and I'll come back to this specific
point. Then there was an analysis of circulating tumor
DNA, transcriptomic profiling, single-cell RNA seq.
So a complex
set of
multi-omic analysis that have been
performed by the authors. The
main conclusion that we
can draw from the large amount of data that have
been discussed is that tumors who
acquired resistance have a lineage plasticity,
epithelial-mesenchymal transition,
metabolic rewiring, and
mixed signaling. So those are basically
the major findings that the authors did
in terms of
the analysis of all the omics that they
have investigated. So the
conclusion of the authors is that, of course,
and this is important
because it's an issue and will be an issue and is an issue in the
clinic, IO resistance is for sure
multifactorial and cancer cells acquire
a number of
mechanisms that allow them to
escape the immune system.
And there is an evolutionary cost, of course, of this IO
resistance because those damages
may somehow become
targets for novel
therapeutic strategies. So they can create
some actionable vulnerabilities.
Now,
as I said, this study captures the complexity and
heterogeneity of immune resistance
to design personalized immunotherapy
in patients who have failed IO. A few considerations
that I have shared with the authors
over the last few days.
Those are not paired samples. It would be nice
to have a cohort of patients, a
hopefully large cohort of patients with paired
samples, in which over time we
can evaluate the changes
and some of the changes that the authors could have
identified in single specific individuals.
The additional three
points I would like to briefly discuss
concern
the
high and low TMB that has been identified,
whether this should be integrated with neoantigen and
TCR repertoire. This is mostly a question for the authors.
Whether multi-omic analysis are planned and
integrated multi-omic analysis as planned.
And lastly, since we work on epigenetics, what
the authors think about epigenetics, and in
particular, this important DNA methylation.
Now, very quickly,
authors have found that a higher
TMB is present in patients with an acquired resistance.
This is somehow important because it distinguishes
acquired
versus primary resistance. And
hopefully in a further analysis, since we know
that clinical benefit from an immunotherapy depends
from the full immunogenic cascade,
neoantigen generation, HLA presentation,
T cell recognition rather than the
absolute number of the
mutations.
This will be important, unless I
missed it in the presentation, for a further
analysis of this large sample cohort.
Those are just a few papers that are highlighting
that the value of TMB per se,
opposite to what we all thought a few years ago,
is not sufficient to identify those patients in
those tumors who will respond better to immunotherapy.
The second point we also discussed with the
authors is whether they plan for
an integration of the
different omics that they have performed.
This somehow will be important
for the future and to take the full advantage
of this large cohort of patients that has been
analyzed. But in addition to
those, let's say, suggestions that I could raise
to the authors then that we discussed, actually,
my
main other question is what about
epigenetics?
Among the omics that have been
investigated, there was at least not presented
no analysis of the epigenetic landscape of these
tumors.
Personally, I feel thatThat would
be a nice addition to what we have
seen in this cohort of patients. As you all know,
epigenetics has become a hallmark of
cancer. And
why I think that epigenetics can be important.
Because I will share with you briefly a few data.
We have understood that DNA
methylation defines subsets with your
patients who will or will not respond to
immunotherapy. So DNA methylation has
a predictive value in terms of
understanding whether patients will
respond to the immunotherapy. This
is just as an example, the
case of mesothelioma patients. Here we took a cohort of
roughly 100 patients, and
we investigated the epigenetic landscape, the methylome
of these patients, dividing them in four different
categories, from low to
SIM,
where low patients have a low
tumor methylation,
the SIM have the hypermethylated tumors.
And there is a very nice correlation between the
level of DNA methylation in the tumor and the
response to therapy. This is mainly
mediated in the low tumors
through the activation or through the
presence of activated immune pathways, and it does not
correlate with the tumor
mutational landscape. So
epigenetics
seems to be
something that helps to predict response to
immunotherapy regardless of the tumor mutational
landscape. This is somehow an irrelevant concept
because we know that the DNA hypomethylating agents
are capable to
induce and activate a number of immune
functions based on these findings.
What we did, we
investigated the combination in a phase one trial, the
combination of DNA hypomethylating agent N and
anti-CTLA-4. This was a few years ago.
And basically what came out from this study is
that
by integrating methylation and levels of
methylation and expression, we were able to
identify a number of genes immune in
responder patients who were upregulated by the
treatment over time. So in serial
biopsies with a global DNA methylation and
with a global DNA demethylation of transposable
elements that was mainly observable in
patients who responded to treatment.
Again, no relationship with the tumor
burden, with the tumor landscape.
The last question
I have that stresses again in responding in
refractory patients, in my opinion, the role
of the epigenetics and of DNA hypomethylating
agents
comes from the study that
is a randomized study in which patients refractory to
an anti-PD-1 treatment,
one second, to an anti-PD-1 treatment, either
melanoma or non-small cell lung cancer,
were treated with a combination of an
anti-CTLA-4 and an anti-PD-1
with or without a DNA hypomethylating agent.
Well, the results at molecular level
that we have generated clearly demonstrated that
the triple combination upregulates and
induces genes that are not
induced by the ipilimumab and
nivolumab combination alone. This is
mainly observable in patients who
are responders to treatment and enriches
pathways again that are immune. So
some of these data, if you like, are included in a
poster that will be presented this afternoon.
But I think that in conclusion,
what we have seen for the non-small cell lung cancer that we just
cleared, whether this will be integrated
also with the analysis of the epigenetic
landscape of these tumors will help us to understand
better how to treat our patients in the future.
Sorry, I was a little bit late.
Well, thank you to both of our speakers.
In the spirit of ending on time, we will do that, so we will not have a discussion
on this. However, I do
encourage you to reach out to
Archana Balan with any questions about
her presentation
as well as Dr. Mao for his discussion. Thank you both very much.
And thank you all for being in this session. I hope you enjoyed it.
We had four wonderful abstracts and four great discussions.
So thank you so much.